IT'S THE DIFFERENCE IN THIS
HALF.
>> Mike: KYRIE IRVING,
LEFT-HANDED -- OH, SWEET MOVE
FROM KYRIE IRVING.
HE DIDN'T JUST SCORE, HE MADE IT
LOOK SO NICE.
NESMITH ON THE DRIVE.
HIGH OFF THE GLASS, MISSED.
TIPPED OUTSIDE TO GRIFFIN.
GRIFFIN BACK FOR DURANT --
DURANT, OH -- OH HE GOES DOWN
HARD OVER SMART.
AND AN OFFENSIVE FOUL CALLED.
I'M SURPRISED DURANT JUMPED UP,
THE WAY HE LANDED, DORIS --
>> Doris: SCARY, MIKE.
>> Mike: WOW.
>> Doris: HE COULD HAVE HURT A
HIP OR HIS RIGHT ARM ACTUALLY
ENDS UP BURIED BENEATH HIM.
LEGS TAKEN OUT, COULDN'T GET HIS
HANDS DOWN, THAT IS A TERRIBLY
FRIGHTENING FALL.
>> Mike: DURANT PICKS UP HIS
FIRST ON THE OFFENSIVE, BUT
APPARENTLY OKAY.
SMART.
CALLING FOR A CLEAROUT.
WANTS TO POST UP KYRIE IRVING.
AND DRAWS THE FOUL.
IRVING'S FIRST PERSONAL.